this is sebastian luke meissani cooper
anderson cooper is officially a father
of two i wanted to start off with some
good news which also happens to be very
personal news on thursday the cnn anchor
announced the arrival of his second
child on his show anderson cooper 360.
revealing he's welcomed a baby boy named
sebastian who will join cooper's eldest
son wyatt
this is wyatt today he's nearly 22
months old and he is sweet and funny and
the greatest joy in my life if he looks
particularly happy in this picture it's
because
he now has a baby brother
his name is sebastian and i would like
you to meet him and the proud dad is
already smitten with his new bundle of
joy he was 6.8 pounds at birth and he is
healthy and happy
even his occasional hiccups are to me
adorable he mostly just
sleeps and eats and he certainly poops
but he already seems like a wise and
thoughtful little chap
cooper also reveals that sebastian was
welcomed via surrogate just as his big
brother was and that the siblings will
be raised together by two loving fathers
wyatt and now sebastian are being raised
by me and my best friend and former
partner benjamin masani we're co-parents
wyatt calls me daddy and benjamin is
papa we're a family benjamin is also in
the process of adopting wyatt so wyatt's
last name will be changed soon to
maisoni cooper as well and anderson
takes a moment to recognize those who
gave him the opportunity to become a dad
again we want to thank the amazing
doctors and nurses who helped bring
sebastian into the world and most of all
thank the surrogate who carried
sebastian and gave birth to him with the
birth of his second son cooper is taking
some time off from work to get close
with his newborn and we're already
seeing some precious moments together
check out this sweet photo with baby
sebastian cooper gush is in the caption
nothing better than this
congratulations thank you to all of you
what a wonderful blessing i appreciate
it and now the journalist is receiving
an outpouring of love from his friends
and colleagues like don lemon who said
congratulations sebastian is lucky to
have you as a dad and kelly ripa who
posted a screenshot of the announcement
oh that's nice you'll remember back in
2020 cooper welcomed his first child
wyatt a moment he called a blessing on
monday i became a father
never actually said that before out loud
and it still kind of astonishes me
i am a dad i have a son and i want you
to meet him
this is wyatt cooper and he is sweet and
soft
and healthy
and i am beyond happy
as a gay kid i never thought it would be
possible to have a child and i'm so
grateful for all those who paved the way
and last year during a visit to the
ellen degeneres show cooper shared his
hopes to someday expand his family i
would love to
i think it'd be great for him to to have
a
i'm not sure i can handle like another
but he's he's really such an easy kid i
mean he's still sleeping like 12 and a
half hours every night he
eats his sweet peas and his mushed
cauliflower and
yeah he's just um he's just a happy
little chappie
it's such a joy turns out dreams do come
true congrats to the happy family on
their newest edition
[Music]
you